here I come I'll be there when this day
is done
country singer Jake Flint has died his
Unexpected death came just hours after
his wedding to his wife Brenda Jake was
37 years old
[Music]
I spent mine
the musician's publicist confirmed the
sad news to the Oklahoman on Monday
explaining Jake died in his sleep after
he and Brenda exchanged vows on Saturday
his cause of death has yet to be
announced meanwhile Jake's wife shared
her shock and grief on Facebook
following their special day Brenda
writes quote we should be going through
wedding photos but instead I have to
pick out clothes to bury my husband in
people aren't meant to feel this much
pain my heart is gone and I just really
need him to come back I can't take much
more I need him here
[Music]
back to my home sweetheart
Jake found his passion at a young age he
started playing music after his dad a
big music lover was diagnosed with ALS
the country star released his first
album I'm not okay in 2016. I'm drowning
myself
[Music]
and his sophomore self-titled album four
years later
in his house tonight
the heater it ain't burning near half as
bright
cold in the day as it is it is in
the cold
in this house tonight
in a statement shared with ET Tuesday
Jake's rep reflected on his legacy
calling him a prolific songwriter
recording artist and in-demand live
performer he also spoke to Jake's
kindness and humility explaining he was
a tireless supporter who was always
willing to lend a hand
foreign
[Music]